trump
hints at launching his own social media
platform and the first subscriber is
adam sosnick
former president donald trump has teased
the launch of his own social media
platform but did not provide
a timeline or offer any further details
regarding the potential business venture
i'm doing things having to do with
putting our own platform
out there that you'll be hearing about
soon trump said on fox news contributor
lisa booth's debut podcast on monday
trump senior advisor jason miller also
uh previewed plans for the new platform
over the weekend saying that the former
president would be returning to social
media in probably the next two to three
months
after being banned from twitter facebook
and other social media platforms
trump has taken to releasing statements
through his post-presidency office and
political action committee
in recent months what do you think is
going to happen with trump
launching his own social media platform
well i know you're you may even have a
name
you're a big data guy well it's not
parlor is that not what it is no
um well i heard that the site is going
to flag
any statement that turns out to be true
you're so
so anything that comes out there if it's
true they're going to flag it and be
like wow
trump told the truth that's crazy so
those statements will be flagged you are
so
um i would like to know uh uh our good
friend jason miller he says
we'll be returning to social media in
probably in the next two to three months
yep two to three months so and we also
have our other friend alan lickman who
does not think that trump is gonna be
running for president
in 2024 um he's off of social media
completely so if he
has any chance of ever winning uh
presidency again he's gonna need some
sort of social media platform
and this might be the key but uh tom
okay here's a guarantee this is a
prediction for me which is also a
guarantee which means it will happen
mark this one down 100
this social media platform will be made
out of solid gold okay
like everything else he does he'll have
it gold-plated the logo or something
will be gold um here's why i don't think
it's going to it's like the gold toilet
yeah
or or the gold faucets that's maradona
the gold faucets on his boeing 757 which
is rotting at an air
hunter right now okay um it's not gonna
work and i'll tell you why because you
don't rush something like this out
you're already giving people
two to three months to prepare to not
provide a platform for him aws or
wherever he's gonna have to go
you know there's gonna be some people
that are gonna be against this it was
all the miller's comments were cliches
it's to be the hottest ticket in social
media we're going to redefine the game
a lot of high-powered meetings are going
on at mar-a-lago he had no details no
facts
nothing here makes me believe that he's
going to have his own platform
meanwhile there's been a covet outbreak
in mar-a-lago and the whole thing's shut
down from what i hear
wow that's not false that's uh that's
that comment is not being flagged no no
it's
not gonna be sympathetic for them in the
middle of a pandemic by the way we're
not in the middle of a pandemic we're on
the uh
the back end of the pale end of it yeah
because of it and the way krispy kremes
is doing it's going to be done in no
time so are you
excited for trump's new uh social media
i'm excited about strategies that's what
i'm excited i'm curious to know what
the next five 10 15 moves of truth
you've been very outspoken
that you want him to curate the next set
of leaders like you want him to have
sort of like a trump university or trump
like well listen influence the next
generation
yeah the the challenge is everything's
been surrounded around
him now it's about does he develop other
leaders and teach them how to become you
know
the same way that he went from where he
was at to being a pretty
well-known figure the most well-known
figure in the world i mean everybody
around though
he had so much influence let me tell you
what happened to different businesses
okay check this out
if you haven't felt the itch to check
twitter 24 7 skim your preferred news
site or keep cable news humming in the
background
president trump left office joined the
club a few months into the new biden
administration news consumption has
significantly declined according to
washington post
cnn lost half of its primetime
viewership in the key
25 to 54 demographic in the period
president's biden's inauguration on
march 15. let me say that one more time
half half of prime time 25 to 54. that's
a 30
year span 25 to 50. money is that's
where the money is
online from january to february unique
visitors to new york times website
dropped 17
while washington post uh clocked in 26
decline washington post does this
article and they say we're down 26
okay so you know there's credibility
there trump's dramatic time in the
office was like san francisco in 1849
for media companies
that covered politics the new york times
check this out the stat
the new york times started off his
presidency with three million paying
subscribers
by the time trump was out how many
subscribers do you think they had seven
and a half million
look at the kind of money he made new
york times cnn has its best year ever in
and drew more viewers 25 to 54 than fox
for the first time in 19 years in q4
throwing the onset of global pandemic
and door bursting subscription deals and
news companies were
inundated with traffic right following
with this but now
new york times warned last november that
subscriber games would start to slow
down
once number 45 left and it's investing
more resources into games and cooking
and other stuff
okay and and then on the bottom line it
says with dc going from house of cards
to c-span 2 the focus is shifting from
filibuster to stonks and you know he
goes in to talk about other stuff here
here's the reality of it this guy gets
eyeballs yeah no matter what anybody
says this guy gets eyeballs
and what's gonna happen with the social
media side if it's just around his name
it's gonna fail if he goes and hires the
smartest and the brightest and overpays
these guys and brings a killer team
that's done this before and recruit some
talent away then it's got a shot
but it's not going to be if he just gets
his people that he's going to need some
real solid engineers who have done this
before
with facebook with google with other
platforms like linkedin and twitter
if he draws those people in which i'm
willing to bet there's some out there
and he brings a couple hundred of them
on board and he brings the right money
behind him to do this
i think this can have legs so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]